daha çok yerde bugüne kadar konuşmalarda
bulundum özellikle benim için gençler
Çok önemli çünkü bugün konuşacağımız
alan çok kısa dakikalarda sizin geleceği
inşa edebileceksiniz alanlardan bir
tanesi Aslında ben sizinle hepimizin
yaşadığı bir hayat örmüştüm başlangıcım
lan Nereye geldin aktarmak istiyorum
hepiniz doğduğumuzdan itibaren
ebe-hemşire ya da Hekim Hekim çıktığı
zaman bizleri gördüğümde bir cinsiyetler
Yani bizim biyolojik bir gireceğiz
kızımıza da oğlunuz oldu Oysaki yaşam ve
şunu gösteriyor cisim onca vurun
gerçeğini sana söylediğim gibi kadın
ben askerden olur aslında ben buna şu
bekliyorum dedim erkekle olan erkek olur
ve Bu süreçten sonra toplum bize mağaza
kıyafetleri giydim yavaş ve biz bu
kıyafetlerle birlikte renklerin
ayrışmasında nohutlu oynadığımız
oyuncaklara Yaşamımızın her alanına
giden evde yüklendiğini bu rollere kadar
hayatımız şekillenmiş aslında bizi
biyolojik organımızda tanımlayan şey
toplumun tanımladığı bir olaya gitme
Yani bir kadın ya da erkek diye bir
şekil almaya başlar yani Beşir verir
olmaz çıkıp toplumun kıyafetlerini
birlikte yine başlıyoruz ve bu yaşamı
küsüm hayatınızda başka sıfat landırma
var geçiyor mikropat landırma lar n n
Aslan oğlun var başlıyor değil mi
prenses Kızım başlıyor
Bu prenses Narin korunması kullanması
gereken yani biyolojik cinsiyetinin
birileri tarafından kız olduğunu
söyleyecek kadın kafana bana giyeceksin
Evet bazı roller ne için erkeklere Aslan
oğullarım bir tarafa güç verirken bir
tarafa bir sürü güç ve korunması gereken
bir cinsiyet bu yüklenenler hayatımı
nasıl şekillendiriyor işte bir maçı 500
ilişkisi karşıma çıksın güçlü ve güçsüz
ilişkisi nerede oluyor işte o Aslan
oğlum dediğim Ormanın kralı dedi senin
sözün geçer dediğim erkek cinsiyeti ne
Affet diyorlar Bir gün bir bakıyorum ki
Aslanlar ceylanlara yemeye başlamış
Çünkü Hayatıma giren şiddet
Bu bir davranış içip hepimizin
öğrendiğini davranış bir güçlü söz
ilişki aşk bu düşün ve kültür ilişkisi
nerede Beni Affet etmeye başlıyor yani
ifade edemeyen kendini anlatamayan
Ormanın kralı yani annesinin babasının
Aslan oğlum dediği erkek cinsiyeti ne de
yüklenen yerler de o kurulması
kullanması gereken niye ad verilen kadın
rolü üzerinde hükmetmeye başladı anla
birlikte aşman cinsiyet enerji beslediği
şiddetli çıktı Yani maalesef içi şiddet
daha çok cinsiyetler arasında
başladığımda erkekten kadına uygulamış
bu yaşamak üstüne şekilde enerji şimdi
yaşamın her alanına yazmaya başladım
çünkü dünyada her üç kadından biri ha
Bu bir şekilde bir dönemde fiziksel ya
da cinsel şiddet gece maalesef
Türkiye'de bor ama Türkiye'de her beş
kadından 3'ü Hayatının bir şekilde bir
yerine İşte biz buna şöyle diyoruz Bu
çarpılmış kadın yoktur maalesef kadınlar
sadece biyolojik cinsiyetleri ha kadın
doğduğu için yaşamlarının her alanında
cinsiyet ayrımcılığı cinsiyet eşitliğine
ve maalesef bir yerinde sıcak Tamam biz
Evet söylediğim gibi şimdi öğreniyor Muş
öfke bizim duyduğumuz bununla bunu
karıştırmayalım şiddet bir davranış için
yemek yemek yürümek gibi ve biz
gördüğümüz zaman bunu öğrenmeye
çalışıyoruz bir çocuk şiddetini soruyor
çocuk
değerli Ailemizde öğreniniz ve şiddet
görmek şiddet ortamında büyüyen
çocukların yaşamlarını şekillendirirken
Aslında iki yıllık açıyormuş istismara
açık çocuklar ihmalle uğradıkları için
ve servis aldıkları içine bebeğin
olduklarından ya şiddet uygulayan ya da
uygulanan olma ihtimali çok yüksek Yani
bugün benim ben şiddete maruz soruyorum
Ses veriyorum beni dur diyen bir kadına
ya da çocuk ses vermediğim her dakika
bir Nesrin Daha buna maruz kalmasına ne
yazık ki sebebiyet veriyor Peki bu
şiddet Hayatının her alanında nasıl
paylaşmak istiyorum sadece fiziksel
çıkmıyor Biz pskolojik çıkıyor yeter
çıkıyor ekonomik çıkıyor dijital
Evet bugün sizinle çok yoğun olarak
yaşayabileceğiniz dijital şiddetli çok
yaygın siparişi deprem İzitaş şiddet
dediğimiz şiddet alanı karşıma çıkmaya
başladı diyor şiddeti karşıma çıkmıyor
yani şiddete sessiz kaldım şiddeti
tanımlayamadığım ve algılayamadım her an
her saniye şiddet Gittikçe büyüyor
yaygınlaşmaya baş bunun için nasılsın ya
da ne yapmam ya da neyi farketmeyecek
bir kere yalnız değilsin diyebileceğim
İşte bunun için Türkiye'de ve dünyada
birçok örgütlenme oluşur bunlar hak
temel insan haklarınızı Bir taraftan da
kadının insan haklarının sabuna olacağım
merak karşımıza çıkıyor dayanışma
dernekleri danışma merkezleri tamamen
gönüllü yolu affetmiş merkezler rahatlar
olacak
Ben bugün aslında bizi bir araya gelecek
Bir taraftan benim uzun yıllardır
sanatları ve kadının insan hakları
üzerine çocuk hakları üzerinde
çalışıyoruz boş halkın Kadın Dayanışma
demem birçok alanda kadının anne çıkan
eşitsizlikleri gördüğünüz 20 yıllık
akademik yaşamı içerisinde edenlerin
karar mekanizmalarına iş yaşamına ve her
sahaya kırılmadan önce ciğerlerim
taraftan da aslında şiddet
engelleyemedim bizden ne toplumun ne
rollerine eşitsizliklerini
değiştiremediğimiz işte bu sebeple 2012
yılında bir grup aktivist bir araya
gelerek Bursa'da tamamen şiddet ve
cinsiyet eşitliğini önlemek üzere
morsalkım kadar dayanışmadan ve buna
7/24 şiddet aklımıza Çelik buna tamamen
gönüllü bir ekip olarak alıyoruz Ve
önümüzden geçen sekiz yıl içinde 7000
üzerinde kadın ve Coşkun üzerinde
çocukla birebir çalış
bu Şiddeti önlemek için sadece bu
geçiyor mu evet kes vermek yalnız
değilsin demek o telefonu açacağım da
yine kes olma yanında olduğunu
hissettiğimde çok Çünkü güçlendirmek ve
adımlarında yanında olabilmek çok
beğendim Bundan yaklaşık altı yıl öncesi
düşünüyorum bizi arayan telefonlardan
bir tanesi hikayede hayatını maalesef
bir köyde geçirmiş maalesef giderken
ekleyeceğim ne olduğunu evlendirdikten
sonra zorla evlendirdikten sonra
yaklaşık 13 yaşlarında zorunlu ve çocuk
yaşta evlendirilen ve aile fertleri
tarafından maaş fiziksel ve Psikolojik
şiddet uygulayarak uzun bir süre üzerine
dokuma geçirildikten sonra hızla yaşamak
için ne olan altının üzerinde çocuğu
diyorum size bunlardan üç dört tane
çocuğunu alarak bir değişiklik saçma
geldim Şu an bir şekilde elini
dokunduğunuz bu
bu göz nereye gelir Biz de buradayız
dediğimiz bu kadın ve çocukları
çocukları için yaşamlarına devam ederken
bu kadın iş yaşamayacağız ve kendi
hayatını kazanabilen çocuklarıyla güçlü
durabilen o zaman ces verirsem ve yalnız
değilsin dersem şekilde ben bilgilerine
dokuna Biliyorum tabi bu yaşam
hikayelerini yanı sıra bir çocuğun da
gelecek ve yaşamını değiştirebilmek
açısından seslere bilmekte yerde çünkü
bununla birlikte Aslında hayatını
bütünüyle gönderdim Yoksa siz o çocuğa
dokunmadığınız çocukla ilişki kuramadığı
zamanda da annesine model alan bir
hayata mahkum kalmasının önüne geçmeniz
tabi bu arada var olmuş bir şiddetin
yaşamları etkinlikten sonra dokuna
bilmenin yanı sıra yapmamız gerekir
buhar olan şiddetin önüne için
bu dediğimiz zaman Aslında bunların
hepsi ikinci plan nasıl önüne geçeceğiz
Öncelikle cinsiyet eşitsizliğini ortadan
kaldırabilecek her çalışmayı yapmak
toplumun bize yüklediği bu kılıfların
aslında bize geçirdik kadına erkeğin
biyolojik cinsiyet Her ne olursa olsun
bunu fark edebilmek her türlü
ayrımcılıktan uzak durabilmek Biz bunu
elimizden geldiğince bunu zaman cinsel
kimlikler cinsel yönelimlere bunlara
dair bugün burada kadın ve erkek
konuşuyorsan biyolojik Temelli konuştum
sonra bunların karşısında durabilmektir
Peki biz gelecek nesiller adına ne
yapmalıyız özellikle sizlerin yaşamın Ah
farkında olmadan Tabii ki medyadır dış
etkenlerde giren şiddetin yanı sıra
biraz şiddet yaşam özellikle gençler ve
yaptığım çalışmalarda buna dair açma
Neler yapmayı çok önemli nedendir
bu çünkü bir sonraki adım ilişkilerinizi
şekillendirmek uzun süreli ilişkiler
oturabilir Bu sebeple güvenli bir
ilişkinin Ne oldu çok yaptım çalışmada
karşıma çıkan etkenlerden buluşup Hocam
beni çok seviyorum Beni de kıskanıyorum
çok hoşuma gidiyor bakın özellikle
kıskançlık üzerinde durmamız lazım işte
benim sosyal medya şifrelerinde
onunkiler de beğendim aslında bir
dijital şiddetli bir psikolojik jip
güvenliğine ilişkin içerisinde ıslaklık
yoktu Güven vardır Biri Sevgi vardır
birbirine dostluk vardır aktarım vardır
birçok ne yazık ki erkekten de kadından
bakayım ben kız kalmazsam beni
sevmediğini başlıklı sevgilisine benim
Bunları bir birinden ayırıp
konuşabildiğini zaman Aslında
yaşamımızda şiddet var mı ilişkinizde
ne var mı Bunları da fark etmeye
başlıyoruz bunları fark edemediğimiz
noktada yavaş yavaş hayatımızı şiddet
sızmaya başlıyor Bu sebeple Kim gelecek
nesiller kendi hayatımızdan şiddetin
barındırmak açısından yapmamız gereken
en önemli etken cinsiyet eşitsizliğini
ortadan kaldırmak ve ilişkilere yaşama
şöyle bir bir şiddet var mı yok mu diye
bakabilmek çünkü size son olarak önemli
bir örnek vermek istiyorum yapacağımız
çalışmalardan biri yaklaşık 4-5 yıl önce
Bursa ilinde 1100 erkekle birlikte
çalışmaya erkek uzmanlarla birlikte ve
şunu sordu Eşinize sevgilinizin bir
şekilde şiddet uyguladığınız yazılar
yazdılar evetler Hayır bunların
içerisinde Hayır çoğunluktaydı ve
sonrasında erkek uzmanlarımız sonra
annelerde içeri derneklerinden ne
anlattılar için şiddet şu
tek bir soru çekmiş burada çok önemli
bir cevap yazmış bu Biz erkeğin 180 mi
Elif olabilir her şeydir Çünkü benim
eşim öyle düşün Rıza inşası karşımıza
çok çıkıyor biletlerde ilişkilerde
hayatta Çünkü sürekli bir ayı evet
yapacağım bunları da aklınızın bir
kenarında tutabilmek ve yalnız diye biz
Niye bilmek için test vermek için de
önce bilgilenmek gerekiyor ki markete
bilelim hiçbir kadın ve çocuk şiddete
maruz kaldığında yalnız değildir o